okay yeah I'm going to need some help
like mine well in order to you know I'm
intentionally challenged on I'm Nanak
things and thought but the idea of
orthogonal remarks was that I you know I
would I would sit here and I would and I
would try to try to think of something
that that the other speakers hadn't said
well it's a pretty hard act to follow I
like what I do have one one observation
and that is in the morning prabhakar
mentioned lesson he learned from dick
and that is if you can postpone a
decision postponement and and this was
applied to an online algorithm for
caching so now Jeremy just told us the
opposite he went when dick works with
vazirani in Baz Ronnie they start out
immediately make a decision and they and
they sort according to a random ordering
well on the other one they divert they
deferred sorting as long as they could
so the thing you can learn from this is
that give different advice on different
days and then you can always quote
yourself all right now another thing up
I got an improv occurs remark is look I
need somebody who can cookie get me
started on this Macintosh eres basically
yeah actually I might be able to do it
as as soon as you get it wired as soon
as you get wired in but anyway put up
prop occur said that he asked if we
could try to imagine what it was like in
the 70's and I'm going to ask you to try
to imagine what it was like in the 50s
now this might be a little harder but
I'm going to try to explain what it was
like in the 50s when when okay now we
have to get this so that it shows the
whole page so I so I need to to save
this is so i want to show you dicks PhD
thesis which was dated january nineteen
fifty-nine and so dick was 23 years old
and the world was was left of course a
lot different in those days but
especially with respect to computer
science because I as far as I knew there
were almost nobody in the world was was
doing computer science and mathematics
at the same time these were two separate
worlds and I was a math major and I
worked at the computing center but when
I travelled from one building to another
it I just went you hope is completely
different okay no no we don't want this
one this was that this is going to okay
it's going to stop there ok so here is
he yours well no no no no uh-uh so so so
dick at one point rather early it gave
me a copy of his thesis and and I have
to admit I never read it until yesterday
but I but it's really interesting and so
I want to show you something yeah okay
I don't want readout loves I want to
dissipate full screen okay so carries
the thesis book it since it's still in
its automated mode okay let's see what
share full screen mode yeah I'm let's
look at this read out loud whatever that
is it looks sleek know it looks like a
group okay sure okay well there's the
head okay so we're giving away all my
secrets here in blank the screen so I
first I i think i first met dick
actually and correspondent with him a
little bit no in directing through a
mutual friend Ray Miller who had come to
Caltech and I and I got to know ray and
and so I wrote turay about some work
that he'd been doing with dick during
the 60s but I think the first time I
actually met dick was was in the fall of
nineteen sixty eight I that was the year
i was living in princeton and i went to
the stock conference who was called swat
conference in those days switching on
automata theory and it was in
schenectady i met dick at that time and
then then he came out to to Princeton I
want to visit us and so that would have
been just at about the time he was he
was also arriving at Berkeley and and
and my wife remembers that that that
that he had come and he was he would
talk about how he was always working out
at the gym and carrying weight and
lifting weights and things like this and
and she said oh that's nothing I I have
to have two children and and I carrying
40 pounds and every day and
and she said she didn't think dick
understood what she meant until 20 years
later when Jeremy came along huh okay so
um no it it looked it looks like looks
like we're getting going so now as I say
this is January 59 and nobody almost
nobody thought that that there was there
was a connection between mathematics and
computer science I in the in the
computer room we filled with stuff and
took and until we thought it was right
we were using some kind of mathematics
but not not the kind that really was
deserving of a name computer science and
except of course of things like
numerical analysis and and now you
already saw this frontispiece that that
came with his thesis if you look closely
at the bottom it says are 0 th so this
one must have been drawn by paul roth
but anyway this came with my thesis this
is the kibbutz proof artificial reshef
ski proxy and and dick and and paul
other work authors of a paper at the
second fox conference I mean stock stock
thoughts conference in in 61 and and and
so they were co-workers and so and thus
let's look into it oh I see I went the
wrong way this way so you want to get
some idea what's in the thesis and in
the 50s when we did programming we
didn't have a very high level
programming languages Fortran ages come
out but but everybody used use flow
chart since and and from dick's thesis
was largely based on the fact that that
flowcharts are are a nice class of
directed graphs for which you which you
can use arguments based on matrix theory
in topology and so he starts out that
the top knee show shows a flowchart and
then I in the middle one it shows how
you can abstract that into into a nice
directed graph with and and you shrink
some of the vertices so that I the
director graph is a little simpler than
the flowcharts that people were drawing
and then and then he shows that how you
can can I'll make a matrix that that
represents all the paths in the
flowchart and and he can he wants to
consider questions like are there any
are there any parts that can never be
any edges that can never be used in a
you know a path from the start vertex to
the final birthday and and so he
multiplies the matrix so it takes powers
of the matrix and he throws out I terms
that are are redundant and so on so he
developed a kind of mathematics that was
absolutely unheard of at that time as
application to a computer programming
and then I learned that two papers of
fact that he wrote during his student
days at not on his resume and and so I
don't know what these are the first he
wrote but here is one called the
assembly of address free programs for
automatic bill calculation at Harvard
account lab and then I reference 20 at
the bottom here was written for General
Electric Company aircraft nuclear
propulsion about methods of evaluating
cajon fortran for use in specific
specific application now but the real
mind-blowing thing for me was when i got
to chapter 3 and i saw this
and this was an example one of the major
examples in his thesis and its beauty
its it's written in machine language of
univac one and and this is a one of the
very first computers and the univac one
had had 1000 words of memory each word
was 12 6 bit characters so each word it
could could hold not only decimal digits
but it did decimal arithmetic buddy but
not only does northwood but also had
uppercase letters A through Z and and
and [ __ ] some punctuation marks like
you like to see the dashes here and so
this is the this is a program in the
machine language for a UNIVAC one which
I hadn't seen for years and years and I
i went to the internet in order to get a
manual to to figure out what what was
going on and and you know what because i
had never seen a program that dick had
written I I knew it of all the while the
great theoretical work but I I never
understood why he had the knack for
devising a theory that would actually be
relevant to practice and and so the
first instruction this is two columns
that these instructions from triple zero
to zero 59 and each each word contains
two instructions the first six digits
you know the first instruction 11 space
for 80 says it says read 60 start
reading 60 words from tape unit one into
into a block starting at address for you
and and in the next the other half of
this word 31 space for 80 that means
take those 60 words and actually put
them in memory and start reading another
60 and so on so be starting out this
program
and and getting the data and then at the
end of the program the program actually
stops in the right hand column at number
42 of that 999999 that means stop stop
the univac you know they in those days
you sat at the Machine and and and you
had total control over it and and and
when your program was on you it stopped
and and and the instructions in front 61
and 62 there's a rewind tape one rewind
tape too okay so this is very practical
experience not what does this program do
you see at the bottom it says a program
for executing the Euclidean algorithm
and so his his example program was to
was to read in a hundred pairs of
numbers ai and bi and and to calculate
their greatest common divisor GI and and
then we'll store those 100 numbers and
write them out on tape too that was the
purpose of the of the program and and so
he had a flowchart forward of course and
then he did a lot of theoretical
examples about how he could could deal
with well naturally being the nitpicker
that I am and I wanted to secure to you
know assess the quality of its program
and see how it is and so and so I'm
sorry to say I found a bug
so in in instruction 39 where it says
dash dash dash dash you it it should
have actually said k space space space
because you have to clear the L register
other way otherwise there's garbage
sitting at a number a hundred is in the
L register and that it interferes with
with a state to and be to God because it
starts out saying is AI greater than
zero or or not and you negate it but but
the second time through it was actually
testing whether i was was greater than
100 instead of 0 because because you you
hadn't cleared the hell register but
anyway it's a no then i also noticed
that the that there was no test for 0 I
mean it you know if we takin the GCD of
two numbers what do you do if one of
them is zero and this program divides by
0 but it in a way you can say that's
okay because in 1950s GCD was undefined
when one of them was zero and and his in
his division instruction which is number
21 there he has a minus after the D and
and the minus in the UNIVAC once said if
you're dividing by zero stop the machine
if you didn't have the minus there it
would interrupt a location 0 and start
reading in from the tape again oh but
anyway I don't know but but this was a
this was pretty good but but then I got
interested in in the in the calculation
that he's actually doing the of the GCD
because this univac one was was the
world's worst machine in order to do it
I it is your arithmetic a number theory
I mean just to accomplish but a G C D
algorithm was was a heroic feat on the
univac one because it was not designed
it was designed by people who thought of
decimal points at the left of a word and
they didn't think of integers said you
know so
the divided instruction the normal thing
for the divine instruction is to add 5
to the answer because that's rounding it
because because you think of the decimal
point at the left so he has to stand on
his head in order in order to in order
to do this and and so actually
instructions I think it's uh it starts
at it starts at 19 and goes all the way
through 28 that's all that's all just to
calculate the remainder of one number by
another so so anyway I found this quite
an interesting program and and i wrote a
mathematical program yesterday to
simulate of what he was doing because i
couldn't figure out why it worked okay I
mean he was he was shifting numbers of
uh you know here and there and and and
so Anna so I until I this right this is
online if you want to look at you could
you can figure out the program but
anyway i trace the the calculation that
it does to get a G C D and if you look
at where I so the first things are some
definitions of the function that that
simulates what what his unit my program
did it started in five it says okay
let's try taking the gcd of of to sort
of random numbers three one four one
five nine and two seven one eight to 80
which is everybody's favorite numbers to
take gcd of and so it goes through
various iterations calculations and I'm
sure enough at the bottom it gets the
right answer one okay so here I tried
another one I took 37 times 3 14 15 and
with with 37 times 2 718 and and you see
in the middle out six is thirty seven
right so it's duy fine but the next 1i
took 37 times 3 14 and 590 and look what
the output was you know 11 million at
something so hmm what was this okay i
know i told you that that we're oh it
would overflow
but but then I did some more
experimenting and we finally you see
what they're taking it at step 9 gcd of
200,000 plus 4 and 2 and the answer is
200,000 now there was there's something
going on here and it's and it's the
UNIVAC one that's at fault because he
claimed that the that the routine would
work for any any 11 digit numbers but in
fact this is the smallest example but
but the what the actual conditions are
that the that the smaller number has to
be at most six digits and the ratio of
the of the larger to the smaller has to
be at most 10 to the fifth or something
otherwise it could screws up so so
anyway I believe this is in one it was a
really great experience for him in order
to sort of get grounded and develop
beautiful theory the rest of his life
also it probably is why he went to IBM
afterwards because instead of UNIVAC and
but it's it's good grounding and I think
maybe maybe rough for Jeremy UNIX was
good grounding so on for similar reasons
now I want to I want to fast-forward
through 1971 what when when I began a
weekly seminar in combinatorics meeting
at my house and this this is the this is
the first this was the first lecture in
this series October of 71 and and we had
the tradition that I got myself a nice
big book that lawyers used a big leisure
book with a nicely bound and and open it
up and every week everyone who came to
the seminar signed their names and I its
precious now to see all these signatures
I
you know so many years later but you but
here we see well I gave the first
lecture and dicks name is right there at
the top of the second column and can you
recognize it well a lot of other people
from Berkeley like Larry Carter let's
see you go sir okay so ellenburg Ellen
birla can't you see Ron Rivest there but
of course he's a Stanford and and so on
so um it was december of that year when
the lecturer was our em cart and his
lecture was reduce abilities between
combinatorial programs this was so this
was i don't know if it was the very
first public announcement of it maybe
you'd spoken at berkeley however i see
that I some of the first people on the
list here are your students from from
Berkeley although here's David gale too
but but you know Norman sada there are a
lot of people here from from Berkeley on
the list so like so so maybe you hadn't
spoken I perfect but anyway this must
have been one of the first we must have
been what it was yeah so this was we
were the first to hear about thing about
these 21 problems at this time and these
are the you're Richard Stanley you see a
shock Chandrababu Arjun John Gill Ron
Fagin you know Hal gabo Barbara gross
hears from berkeley david luck and Bob
Floyd and so on so this was that this
was the dawn of that now he spoke again
in 1976 and his topic this time was
probabilistic analysis of a heuristic
set covering algorithm and actually this
is a little too what other people have
been talking to
today pretty much because the he had a
dozen or more papers with probabilistic
analysis in the title and those are the
ones that are closest to my own heart
because they they relate most directly
to real computer programs it's in a
worst-case analysis but but but saying
what can we expect to happen it end up
and set covering is of course one of the
NPI problem said that we still are faced
with and so we want to know not only the
worst case but but what is it like when
you have that comment and and so this is
a beautiful results not to not as well
known as it should be because it was
published in this in his book by Joe
tribe of algorithms and complexity that
that you had to buy in order to read it
so you could find in the library but
anyway very and I'm finally getting
around to writing about covering in
about a year oh you know through the 70s
I thought I was going to be coming over
to berkeley to talk to dick about things
like this but but it'll be about a year
that i want to be talking with you about
as i write up this the average cases of
these important algorithms okay now a
little more about this seminar and that
is a mystery because as i'm looking
through the book I you know I showed you
the things on the first line and you see
dick signature their first it was dick
there was a dick karpen and his Richard
carp and then there's there's the carpet
76 now so I so I know that on the one
occasion when he spoke he signed as
Richard Carpenter second time he signed
his dick cart because I know he was
there that day however on the in 1972 in
December when Ron Graham was talking
people also mentioned their affiliation
after they signed in and look at there's
dick carp Stanford now now we had a
student Richard a carp who always said
you know I'm not the
real one and and so so you know so this
is probably him now in 75 when persi
diaconis spoke we have this signature of
the carp here and then mike geary and
johnson in march we have a signature
dick carp and then Andy y'all spoke in
75 to and there's the carp and NN 79
when lovas talked we have Richard carp
I'm sure that's a thick but which of the
others is authentic this is the mr.
mystery maybe you can help me solve that
okay no I'm about done but i but i did
want to say you know you people brought
up all this besides all the wonderful
research and and it was also his
community service and and i was looking
at the at the stock fox bibliography
that that david johnson put together 25
years ago and and at that time it was a
survey of the first of 30 years of of
the both the stock at fox conferences
and at that time well 32 years i guess
because David gave statistics at the end
and and so so dick was the it was the on
the program committee more nine times
and and the second most common was was
people who served seven times so so he
did more service on program committees
than anybody else he also was the what
was I longest in what Dave Johnson
called longevity which was the time
difference between the first your first
paper in the Indies conferences and and
the last and and and and so we had a
31-year record of longevity and the
second second place was 29 so so
the most important it important thing
though comedians to you know of all the
awards that he that he received the I I
noticed also that that Berkeley gave him
its distinguished teaching award in 1986
now this is really really a remarkable
because usually the people who get the
distinguished teaching award are
wonderful teachers but but that's their
life and I know that I could never win a
distinguished teaching award of so then
so this to me is is one of the greatest
in a way greatest things on his resume
shows this really love of students that
that is why I they were that is why he
is well has won the hearts of so many of
us so thank you very much for all easy
you have a rebuttal well I'll be very
brief this has certainly been one of the
most delightful experiences of my life I
will never forget it if even a fraction
of the things that were said were really
true I would be insufferable at home but
even though I know there's a certain
amount of inflation and in these
encomiums I appreciate the spirit of it
very much I would like to thank Alasdair
Ravi and christos for organizing this it
was a lot of work also our staff at the
Simon's Institute in particular you to
do tell ren ren zhen gas co has worked
very hard as my wife Mary Jo has also
done and the last thing the most
gratifying thing of all is that when I
was asked to nominate speakers for this
event I thought about the people who
were my most important mentors my most
important role models people with whom I
had worked most gret in a most
gratifying way and and so these were the
people who in one way or another meant
the most to me and all 13 of them all 12
of them accepted and my clue be the
thirteenth would have accepted except
that he had
unbreakable get the conflict so fact I
know how hard it is to travel and come
to an event of this kind you know you it
takes time and effort and the fact that
these dozen people were all willing to
do it mom's my heart very much